hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
you can't mention the word PC without
thinking of Microsoft originating as a
competitive startup in the 1970s the
company took over personal computing in
the 90s so that's the new Windows 95
interface simpler far more intuitive not
without a few problems though but in
general a great improvement
Microsoft is now worth about 750 billion
US dollars making it the fourth most
valuable company in the world perhaps
just as well-known as the for Windows
low though is the company's
philanthropist founder Bill Gates who is
90 billion dollar net worth makes him
the second richest person in the world
things may look crazy now but at one
point
Bill Gates was hated by the public and
Microsoft was being sued by the US
government for breaching antitrust laws
the story of Microsoft and Bill Gates is
one of incredible genius controversy as
Microsoft tried to take over the world
so just how pervasive is Microsoft and
how did it all start and what are some
interesting facts about the company sit
back and relax and I'll tell you all
about it in this video
[Music]
Bill Gates was born in 1955 in Seattle
as a child he enjoyed playing risk a
world domination game and monopoly a
game where players in Osito economy
crushed their opponents financially
these games perhaps nature to
competitiveness and ruthlessness and
gates which he later brought to the
business world from an early age Gates
was fascinated with computers in the
1960s when Gates was in high school
Micro computers was starting to take off
there were some of the first computing
machines available to the public while
expensive to the common person micro
computers were far cheaper than the
large mainframe computers used by
universities and large organizations at
the time one of the first market
computers the pdp-8 cost around a
hundred fifty thousand US dollars in
today's money Gates along with future
co-founder Paul Allen and a few other
friends would learn to code by renting
time on corporate microcomputers Gates
and his gang were discovered to be
exploiting bugs in the computers code to
obtain free additional time when the
company found out they struck a deal
with the boys and actually hired them to
search in fix bugs back at school Gates
was so far ahead of the curve that the
school let him build the class
scheduling program coincidentally the
program assigned the young Gates to no
classes on Fridays and classes with a
disproportionate number of girls on the
remaining days the future was bright for
Gates who was said to have an IQ over
160 the story of the Microsoft Company
starts in 1974
Bill Gates was studying at Harvard at
the time when his childhood friend Paul
Ellen showed him a new DIY microcomputer
called the Altair 8800 which was
featured on the cover of a magazine the
computer was done even by standards of
the day all it could do was flash some
lights but gates immediately realized
that with some strong software the
rudimentary machine could become an
affordable personal computer for anyone
to use Gates's insight caused him to
drop out of law school so that he and
Allen could start a software company
just for this purpose logically they
named the company Microsoft which was
software for microcomputers Allen and
gates found the company which produced
the outter 8800 computers and told them
that they had software written for the
machine there's only one problem though
at this stage they hadn't even written
software yet all they had was a company
does this article received immense
interest I mean the idea of a kik
computer even though there was really
nothing you could do with it in the
early days it's pretty useless people
just bought it thinking that it would be
neat to build a computer and it was kind
of in a way you know good news bad news
here was someone making a computer
around this chip in exactly the way that
Paul had talked to me and you know we
thought about what kind of software
could be done for it and it was
happening without us we wrote these this
company immediately two months of
sleepless nights and caffeinated drinks
later they would have a meeting with the
mitts company to showcase their work
despite only relying on a book from a
microchip manufacturer and not even
having an outer machine to test their
code on gates and Alan was successful at
the project because we'd never had the
chip just the book from Intel if we'd
made any mistake in terms of how the
instructions worked it never I think
never would have run and so Paul was
scheduled to fly out to Albuquerque he
decided to go get some sleep
I stayed up all night reading the book
to see if we miscoded some of the
instructions and finally decided it was
all okay punch out the paper tape and
made sure Paul got that before he went
off on his plane he wrote the bootstrap
loader that is the thing you have to key
in to make this computer smart enough to
know to go get data off the teletype to
read it into memory he wrote that on the
plane on the way out was actually 46
bytes the first one I eventually wrote
one in seventeen bytes but anyway and he
typed in a program you know print two
plus two it worked he had to print out
squares and sums and and things like
that and he and and Roberts the end of
this company sat there and they were
amazed by you know that this thing
worked I mean Paul was amazed that that
our part had worked and and ed was
amazed that his Hardware worked and then
here it was doing something even useful
yeah this was the first real piece of
software ever written for a
PC it came for the first generation of
PCs the thing that unlocked the power
that was there the makeshift code would
be the humble start of a revolution soon
people were using out their machines to
process Word documents and play games
Microsoft was in business following the
Altair success Microsoft were going to
provide operating system software for
IBM computers in the 1980s for one-time
fee of $50,000 critically Microsoft held
onto the rights for this software rather
than signing it over to IBM this allowed
them to gain royalties not only for each
license sold on IBM machines but also
for software sold on other PC
manufacturing companies which were
beginning to form at this time such
shrewd thinking caused the IBM deal to
be called the greatest deal in history
and made Microsoft a big player in the
industry sadly this did come at the cost
of gary kildall a losing player in the
deal
he ended up spiraling into depression
and an early death I've already covered
this story so I'll leave a link below if
you want to watch it as a result of the
deal Microsoft and Bill Gates became
synonymous in this new age of personal
computers in the early days
Microsoft also worked with Apple to
create software for Apple's Hardware in
fact gates featured on the Macintosh
1984 promotional video the development
of Macintosh by Apple has been
paralleled by the work of leading
software developers it's a great machine
it's a step forward in terms of the way
it uses graphics and the speed I was
enthused we're planning that over half
of our retail sales next year will come
from from Macintosh software the rivalry
between Microsoft and Apple and he
started later that year when Gates
announced plans to make a competing
graphical interface operating system
this was inspired by his time working at
Apple Jobs blasted gates accusing
Microsoft of theft and later filing a
lawsuit even though it was Xerox not
Apple that originally developed the
graphical operating system the
relationship between Apple and Microsoft
is actually a complicated one in fact
Microsoft would go on to save Apple from
bankruptcy in 1997 and the reason they
did so is just as interesting as the
fact that they did
flashback to 1986 and Microsoft is
writing a Fame wave having just released
their Windows operating system followed
by their office suite Microsoft's IPO
will go on to create three billionaires
and approximately 12,000 millionaires by
the mid-1990s Microsoft would land in
hot water in 1994 the US Department of
Justice filed a statement saying that
Microsoft had been engaging in
anti-competitive behavior the company
was pulling PC manufacturers to pay
Microsoft a licensing fee not only when
Windows operating systems were installed
but also when a competitor's software
was installed the Department of Justice
was represented by David Boies the same
lawyer who would go on to represent the
medical startup fraud theranos the
pressure was building at Microsoft as
the investigations continued at this
time Gates was not at all a
philanthropist and was generally
disliked by the public who was at this
executive staff me
[Music]
probably members of the executive staff
I went through the chain of logic that
explains that to you I don't know if you
misunderstood some part of it while I'm
trying to do is get your answers on the
record because if I begin to tell you
what I think about your answers we'll be
here all day
meanwhile Apple was on the brink of
bankruptcy with only 90 days of cash
left in 1997 Jobs announced that Apple
would enter a partnership with Microsoft
much to the dismay of fans at Mac well
we're gonna be working together on
Microsoft Office on Internet Explorer on
Java and I think that it's gonna lead to
a very healthy relationship so and I
happen to have a special guest with me
today via satellite downlink and if we
could get him up on the stage right now
Microsoft was stepping to save the day
giving Apple a hundred fifty million
dollars in exchange for shares an
agreement where Microsoft Office would
be included on every Mac for the next
five years but this move also helped
Microsoft appear to help their
competitors rather than illegally bully
them Microsoft was settled in 2004 with
the judge calling Microsoft and a piece
of monopoly once it was all over gates
sold all of his Apple stock Microsoft
spent the 2000s as a household name
however the stock price remained
relatively stagnant gates and his wife
Melinda launched the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation in 2014 and bill would
make the foundation his full-time
project Gates pledged to give away 95%
of his wealth in his lifetime
needless to say Gates is philanthropy
won him many supporters in the general
public
although Gates is invested in efforts
for Alzheimer's disease poverty famine
and global health
the foundation has faced some criticism
over some of the other causes that are
donates to Gates's current Quest is to
reinvent the toilet challenging
researchers and companies to invent
cheap sanitary toilets for the
developing world perhaps one day
Microsoft will just be a small footnote
in the life of Bill Gates so just how
big as Microsoft's daddy though the
market share of their operating system
has slowly been declining an astonishing
75 percent of PCs still run Windows in
2018 Microsoft's revenue was 110 billion
u.s. dollars that's enough to give every
person in the world around 14 dollars
and 30 cents if Microsoft was a country
you'll be the 37th wealthiest 193rd most
populated Microsoft owned Skype github
Bing hotmail Xbox LinkedIn and Nokia
Microsoft also has substantial
investments in uber AT&T Facebook just
to name a few significant buy ins and is
looking to grow more since gate stepped
away from a full-time role of Microsoft
his stock price has grown almost
exponentially doubling in a five-year
period this is largely due to the
company's rebirth under the new CEO
Satya Nadella
Nadella oversaw the acquisition of
LinkedIn which unlike the seven billion
dollar no key acquisition is considered
a far greater success Satya Nadella also
eased the rivalry with Apple announcing
in 2014 that office apps will become
available on iOS and Android Microsoft
has also launched their range of surface
laptops and other hardware the company
is diversifying and getting its fingers
in a lot of pious it has recently made
acquisitions and video games virtual
reality cloud computing and artificial
intelligence
Windows 10 released in 2015 has just
passed 800 million users becoming the
company's most popular operating system
and its installed on 40% of PCs globally
microsoft's hololens to you is pitted to
be an augmented reality game-changer
allowing for a potential great change in
the way that we work and learn microsoft
azure is the second largest cloud
services provider Microsoft edge the
younger brother of Internet Explorer is
also trying to dent the web browser
market and it looks promising and
gaining some users back from Google
Chrome with all of this being said a lot
of the Microsoft businesses helping to
grow the stock price were actually in
place before Satya Nadella took over
so while Nadella has overseen a drastic
change his contribution to it must be
taken with a grain of salt okay so
before we round out the video let's take
a look at some interesting facts about
Microsoft
during the early years of Microsoft
Gates was arrested twice while driving
without a license his mugshot later
became the silhouette for the default
2010 outlook profile avatar Microsoft's
company grounds was littered with
bunnies after someone supposedly left a
bunch of unwanted pets on campus other
reports say that it was a prank
either way the rabbits multiplied and
now they're part of the company
Microsoft beat Apple to the smartphone
back in the early 2000s however the
project never really took off for
Microsoft Microsoft passed an
opportunity to buy YouTube for five
million dollars in 2006 they left the
opportunity wide open for Google to
purchase them six months later and turn
into the Internet's most popular video
hosting service if you type in the text
equals Rand old was open and close
bracket into word and hit enter it spits
out the phrase the quick brown fox jumps
over the lazy dog which contains all
letters of the alphabet at once an
investment of twenty one dollars and
Microsoft in 1986 would have turned out
to be fifteen thousand dollars by 2018
Microsoft employees must bring in M&Ms
to share for their work anniversary one
pound each for each year that they've
been accompanied Bill Gates and
childhood friend Paul Allen had already
founded one business together in high
school before Microsoft it was called
traffic data and as the name suggests in
manage traffic data if it were up to
Bill Gates we may have been calling
Windows interface manager thankfully
some people at marketing thought windows
sounded better Microsoft began
manufacturing Hardware in 1983 beginning
with the Microsoft Mouse before marrying
Bill Gates Melinda worked at Microsoft
on a product called Bob it altered the
user interface to appear as if you're
clicking through a house the aim was to
make computing more inviting to those
not familiar with it needless to say it
was a failure
Microsoft has over 10,000 patterns and
applies for about 3,000 more each year
the bliss background photo is perhaps
the most viewed photo in history
synonymous with Windows XP is bound to
bring back some memories
so that was an interesting look at the
history size and some fun facts about
Microsoft it's interesting because
analysts warned that by losing gates to
a part time advisor role the company
would struggle his presence and the
founder mentality he brought were
thought to be too important but in 2019
this couldn't be further from the truth
Microsoft is a long shot from its
beginnings as a simple software company
over the last forty three years
it's diversified and grown into a
multinational that doesn't look to be
slowing down anytime soon let me know
your thoughts on Microsoft below thanks
for watching this has been - gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion if you
want to know more about that battle
between bill gates and gary kildall and
why gary ended up sadly dying I'll leave
a link to that video below all right so
I'll see you again soon for the next
video cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
you